welcome to ear biscuits I'm late and I'm
Rhett this week at the round table of
dim lighting we once again have Kevin
who we have commissioned commissioned
with a K not really commissioned with
the C he's gone out into the world
it's Kevin that starts with a K yeah
right seeing Kevin spell with the C yes
seven that's what they call it when you
spell out with a c' that's probably you
know there's a dude out there Kevin with
a C coven will the three at the end at
the end
Kevin's convinced how can I convince you
that I'm a bad name is Vince and Kevin
put together Kevin's sounds like
convinced up so I'm not convinced that's
convinced so he went out into the wide
world and you know what he's back today
the world wide web to bring us the most
fantastic stories of humans who have
period that's it that's the new theme
for your biscuit we have most fantastic
stories of humans know Rhett these
humans more specifically have been
masterful gamers of systems they have
found loopholes to take full advantage
and improve their lives sometime I
believe in ultra dramatic ways so
dramatic so he's gonna he's gonna take
us through he's gonna take us on
multiple journeys of gaming the system
yes it's a good conversation it inspired
me raised some moral questions you're
gonna love it now we want to let you
know that this Saturday June 24th we are
going to be on the main stage the Arena
Stage at VidCon so if you're going you
should be there and you should see us
because we're gonna we're gonna record
the 100th ear biscuit yeah live on the
stage and if you can't be there just
wait what we'll give it to you it'll
come straight to your ears yes so this
isn't I mean we are doing some other
things at VidCon but that you you have
to I don't know there's other ways to
get into those things you probably
already know whether or not you're
attending them but this is one that
everyone can go to so come to that 11:00
a.m. unless you're not a big come to
and you're listening to it later that's
all I'm saying yeah yeah you can you can
get access to it but first you know in
in talking about gaming systems gaming
systems we actually used the term a lot
when we when we talked about our job
over the year declared about gaming the
system not gaming systems yeah really
cuz that's like consoles that's true
which we know very little about but we
talk about him all the time yeah I mean
we've been around through a lot of them
yeah Atari Sega was there for Atari
right I was there for Atari didn't
intend but yeah but gaming the system
you make an advantage of something and
with this is something that in that
system for us is YouTube right and it is
you know it's interesting because we if
sometimes you kind of try to explain to
someone from you know traditional media
about how what we do is different and
the way that I've explained it just one
aspect of it I'd be like it's like you
know a person who makes a movie when Wes
Anderson I assume when Wes Angela makes
a movie I I'm assuming that he spends a
good amount of time thinking about the
poster sometimes like oh what's gonna go
on the poster maybe he may not think
about it at all man I would not be
surprised if he didn't but but beyond
that but like or like anything else
beyond marketing like if you go back 15
years you know 10 years when Blockbuster
Video is existed and you went into the
physical store and you made decisions
about what DVD you were gonna pick up
and it's based on the DVD cover it's
like they've impotent it's like a
director being almost as concerned about
the content of the movie I mean almost
as concerned about the DVD cover as they
are the content of the movie because
that's the decision point so I'm making
the point that we think about you're
making them nail you're making an
analogy to the thumbnail but what but
before we get back to thumbnails I'll
add to that but what Wes Anderson
doesn't do is he doesn't start thinking
about what theaters and are going to
show this and then when people exit the
theater how are they going to be able to
give
feedback is there like a yeah is there a
way that they can like like give their
feedback in a comment what can I do with
my movie in the way that I put it out
there that would get more people to talk
about it or care about it oh I can come
on the screen at the end of the movie
Wes Anderson is never stopped watching
my movie if you would like to watch more
of my movies you can go to the local
blockbuster and pin click on pick you
know that's that's the way we think
about things well it's not just how we
think about things we think about what
we're eating but then we also have to
think about the system within which it's
being distributed because it I mean the
system distributes it but it's really it
only distributes as well as you can work
the system alright so and it's you can't
just be an artist but you also have to
be it feels like being an engineer like
like studying and deciphering and also
work also being a salesman of your own
products yep right which we have to do
and I think that so there's the market
isn't there's the functionality and I
think for two reasons at all like it
number one it feels icky to have to
convince people when you say like
comment and subscribe or whatever it
feels a little icky because you're
having to say I'm telling you to like
something that you could otherwise just
make a decision whether or not you like
it right so that feels a little bit
weird and but yet we've gotten to a
place where we say it every single
episode of good mythical morning thank
you for liking commenting and
subscribing you know what time it is but
yeah we'll get back to how we apply it
but the second reason I don't like it is
because it requires an unexpectedly high
amount of energy and thought that goes
into how you're thinking about packaging
the videos that you recreate as opposed
to spending all that time on just
thinking about the videos that we create
right you're going to think about all
the everything else that is not the
thing yeah yes every round how do you
get the thing what do you do with the
thing what makes you decide to click on
the thing because to be clear I mean
liking and commenting on a video feeds
in in ways that we've only guessed
over the years and it's changed month by
month how the algorithm how the machine
of YouTube Indus inhumanely
discriminates in and mainly yeah there's
no human if there's no nut sure if
that's a correct use of the term but I
think I understand what you mean
humanely yeah unn humanely serves up my
video your video our video or somebody
else's videos so we try to gain the
system by gently prompting you gently to
comment to engage because engagement has
to be part of the algorithm and it's a
part of the job that I don't really like
because I like it the work to just stand
on its own but because of the
environment that we're in and because we
actually have control all over all those
variables you puts us in a position
where we necessarily have to be willing
to game the system in order to be
successful however I do think that there
are lines that we draw we've never
really talked about this as sort of an
instinct thing but I think that ok what
you want to talk about thumbnails yeah
so this is sort of the first ever way
that you get game the system is back
before you could upload custom
thumbnails and it would YouTube would
just take it would give you three three
options and you know one of them was
right in the middle of the video like
what Center frame yeah people figure
that out where that where the frames
were at least the middle one and so
people would come up with a really great
thumbnail that may or may not have been
representative of the video that you
were clicking on and they would insert a
flash frame in there that almost
subliminally would come up and you would
barely see it but then they could select
that frame and then use that to sell the
video and they'd be really mad when it
got off by a frame right and so then
there's this weird shot of like boobs we
never did this that shows up in your
video yet it wasn't the thumbnail and
you didn't find out until it went up and
you weren't gonna take the video down
I got there's boobs there's a boobs
frame but didn't even get to take
advantage of a boobs thumbnail but you
get that subliminal message which yeah
might be unexpected boobs I was gonna
complain about that I'm sure people will
but we decided that we we I think we
never we we do we ever do that I don't
think we ever once did that but then
once they
said okay we'll let you create a custom
thumbnail and of course risk all the
ways that you can exploit that and then
of course people did exploit it but then
we start playing the game and find where
our line is to where it's like well
we're gonna game the system but only to
a certain extent but there are certain
people who like I'm an artist I'm really
my thumbnails aren't gonna draw people
and they're just gonna look cool I'm not
gonna put a thumbnail on this at all
like there's people that I respect you
make cool or funny videos back in the
day who would never manipulate a
thumbnail and I've always envied those
people I there's a part of me that's
like yes the pure way to do it and when
I look at the thumbnails that we put on
everything that we do now because by
definition it's manipulative yeah when I
when I look at the thumbnails Zekey that
are on everything that we do it I get an
icky feeling sometimes not because we're
misleading I mean okay would there have
been times where we've been misleading
sure but it's never completely unrelated
to what the subject matter is in other
words we want to draw you in with a
sensationalized thumbnail but then when
you click on it we want this the video
that you get to the thumbnail was
representative of that we're very
careful about that because it'll you
know it'll bite you in the butt later
but there's people go even further than
that so I'm pretty much every every
youtuber is manipulating thumbnails some
more than others there's a line to kind
of figure it out but other things people
do are you know subscriber giveaways
we've never done that that felt like
kind of creating like a lottery system
amongst your subscribers I don't know
don't describe for the content described
to win something described described
twice subscribe I'm a little tired don't
describe to the content describe to the
game I could have gotten away with it
the first time I don't even know how I
feel about that we haven't done it I
don't plan on doing it again because
every step towards that is something
that I don't feel good about I just want
what we do to stand on its own but we're
in a world where there's not there's not
a marketing engine behind what the work
that you do besides anything
you do yourself it's a lot of work look
I mean looking at the thumbnails on good
mythical morning if something's not
gained not reaching certain milestones
then we have conversations but changing
the thumbnails you know it's part of our
system part of our system is looking at
things and you know titles we don't even
talk about titles but mm-hmm if you
could just be a world where it was good
mythical morning episode 1200 or ear
biscuits episode 100 right boom you were
like do you're clicking on it because
you just want it but that's not how
people think people are making a
decision about well I want to know what
it is that I'm clicking on because I
don't watch all your videos there's a
minority of people who actually watch
everything regardless of what it is and
then the vast majority of people make a
decision every single day to say I'm
going to click on this video and I have
to be compelled yeah as opposed to other
videos because it's it's you know in a
sea of other choices that they're
constantly making and then and everyone
else I see this getting much larger by
them yeah that competition so to speak
is there they're manipulated they're
manipulating their photos in their
titles and well and not to go on a
tangent but it is very much relevant to
the way that news works now and this is
one of the reasons I've had a huge just
fall out with fake news it's it's a
result of the clickbait culture and it's
actually affecting the way that we
consume information because we're like
I'm not going to think anything's
important unless you dress it up in a
way that makes me think it's important
and it causes people to begin to do
things to game the system and then all
that matters is if it sells it doesn't
matter if it's true if they got you to
the page anyone if they get you to the
page they win the advertiser wins which
means they win and it's oh so the litmus
test is not you know how well-written or
you know how true is this but it's how
how many people saw it how many people
saw the ad next to it yeah or over or
before it now for us I mean it's it's
it's our livelihood too for people to
you know to support our sponsors or to
be exposed to ads in conjunction with
what we're doing
but our our our goal is to is to get you
to watch the thing obviously yeah I mean
it's like but when you're like just
relaying news I mean I guess we're
journalists they want if they're a
reputable journals they want to be the
source that you go to - it's a tough
situation because there's a part of me
that would just say if I knew that there
were enough people out there who would
just say I am going to pay for you guys
content for your guys content and that's
the only and then we just there's no
sponsorship at all it's just you guys do
exactly what you do and I'm just gonna
pay for it there's a there would be a
purity with that but then there would be
a whole lot of people who are not in a
position to pay but are in a position to
withstand or experience advertise you
know tolerate advertising right there'll
be a lot of that we never get to see the
show we wouldn't be able to reach much
less people who've never even seen the
show I'm not gonna be a for an unknown
product right because - so the
advertiser model is absolutely necessary
and it's gonna continue which may which
is what again we're going on a tangent
on a tangent but which is one of the
reasons that I've always just been
completely you know I think one of the
most hypocritical things you can do is
watch YouTube with adblock on because
you are you're making the decision to
enjoy the content but you're also
simultaneously making the decision to
not support the creators and maybe if
you've got adblock on and then you pay
people's patreon if they have those
things but I think to be - for it to be
a pure decision you would have to have a
block on and only watch people who you
are then supporting through some sort of
other means which in our case we don't
have that means for support it's all
advertising base more if we can also buy
our made by mythical product lines yeah
okay yeah actually like okay but again
but that ain't that ain't gonna cut it
that's not a one-to-one thing knows the
advertisers who are basically financing
the platform of something like YouTube I
think that if they're in some way they
should be
you should assess how the creators are
making a living they should be rewarded
in that way so we're gonna talk to Kevin
about not this type of industry related
in YouTube related gaming of systems but
how other humans have done it too
alarming and amazing and it's certain
points unbelievable success in a second
but first yeah we do want to show some
love to our sponsors and clarify that we
do really appreciate the fact that we
have sponsors of ear biscuits and ads
wherever we choose to place ads around
all of our content because as we've
already said it enables access to you
mythical beasts free of charge and
exposes us to more people so let's show
some love to those advertisers and in
this case today we're sponsoring
ourselves can we do that yeah we can see
what we want man well with with the
merch you all support our internet
payment through our merch actually I'm
holding this up which is also available
in red link com slash store but really
it's what I don't have a liquid in this
right now so I can handle it without
care uh-huh
it is boiled for safety ITER's are
boiled for safety mug exclusive limited
time mug these things are selling like
crazy like hey cake hats which means
they're going to run out relatively soon
and then they go and be get it while
it's hot get it while it's 212 degrees
Fahrenheit or 100 degrees Celsius which
is the degree of water that is boiling
temperature is actually easily how you
say that also we won't actually know
speaking of temperature high temperature
we have a lot of tank we got tanks we
got summer teas we got summer themed
merch clothing it Harold it looks so
good you know you won't have you can
stay cool we can say mythical
go to Ridley Netcom slash store to get
your summer wear and you know what now
let's bring Kevin in and let's make the
rest of this biscuit
[Music]
you're back hey guys I'm back know I act
surprised we asked him to come back all
right I know you know what I did after
we commissioned him for a second trip
around the world to collect information
right because that's how this works I
was like now I'm gonna intentionally
forget it so it'll be a surprise when he
shows up that's why I said Kevin you're
back
what a surprise Kevin I'm a only thing
I'm surprised about is after all that
talk about khakis you're still not
wearing Yeah right
how much do we have to drop a hint I
thought about it I own no khaki you
thought about you oh no khaki zero not
even pants not even pants
I actually I don't have khaki pants
anymore either like that was like well
maybe something my mom made me have
maybe now that I I mean do you I have a
page I'll have them I'm not attacking
you I mean I I think I got one thing
that's khaki but it's not khakis they're
they got their the big big crush the
drop Christ so what you got is out there
you do you have a teaser I do have a
teaser all right hit it I'm gonna talk
to you guys about people who have gamed
the system okay I'm gonna give you a few
stories great stories and in these
stories we're gonna be talking about
pudding oh yeah airline miles
those don't worry it's good okay we'll
be talking about malfunctioning ATM
machines never had that have a best kind
fancy restaurants private jets kanye
west's will make a slight appearance in
this podcast my favorite thing he's
gonna be calling in he oh he won't be
calling in but I'll be calling him in
momentarily the United Nations outer
space treaty you ever heard of this
sounds fake it's not the Galactic
government and the richest man in the
solar system
oh that's right so uh crow no crows you
gotta work in a crow can you I probably
could when we get there khakis or a crow
what are you gonna do The Crow yes I
promise to work in a group I'll get the
crow in there we're gonna jump right off
the bat with a guy named David Phillips
is there personal application for us
either with David Phillips or
with any of these yes cases cuz you're
presenting multiple cases yes it's
personal application for us I think in
particular the last story oh yeah so I
think with all of them it will help us
game the systems of our lives yeah you
don't want to fast-forward to the last
story I mean ever any piece of
information can be applicable to your
life yeah just to explain a little
gaming the system means when somebody
it's like they don't cheat the system
they figure out a loophole cleverly
right to make it work for themselves
yeah yeah it's clever we're gonna hear
some clever totally defensible yes
technically legal yes it's a fine line
though listen to this podcast for
lessons from normal I'm I'm trying to
figure out why I'm listening I trust you
this is what we do man it's a job and
you got me and I'm engaged I care about
this cuz it's gonna make me a better
game engaged well you should who is this
guy this guy David Phillips you're gonna
like this guy cuz I like this guy he's
known as the pudding guy remember I
teased pudding earlier no Bill Cosby
jokes link yeah don't don't talk about
Bill Cosby we'll talk about David he was
a civil engineer at UC Davis okay now
he's the kind of guy that likes to read
the fine print you know and he's also
really good at counting cards he said he
would have been a professional card
player had it not been for the cigarette
smoke in casinos good numbers guy here
likes pudding okay well we'll get to the
pudding okay so in 1999 there was a
healthy choice promotion you know
healthy choice products yeah they have
frozen meals and all kinds of stuff so
they're kind of like Weight Watchers but
they're not they're just a healthy
choice for everybody you don't have to
look not to lose weight yeah exactly
here's their promotion $19.99 every 10
barcodes of their product would get you
500 airline miles so you buy ten
products you cut out the barcodes you
send it in you get 500 airline miles
they had of an airline it was a real
choice here yeah they were tied in with
an airline what make sure the healthy
choice so I have degradable planes there
was an early-bird stipulation that if
you sent it in the first month you'd get
double okay okay so here's what David
did David scoured all the local super
markets in the area made a lot of
healthy choices you've made a lot of
healthy choices looking for healthy
choice products
he found a discount grocery chain I
don't know the name of it but he found a
chain right Piggly Wiggly Piggly Wiggly
I got Aldi he noticed that on pudding
they had individual barcodes on every
cup hold on so you can make a healthy
choice and pudding apparently you can I
mean healthy choice says you can no I
made the healthy choice to stop eating
pudding
a long time ago I know I I just make the
excellent choice to eat pudding
indiscriminately
you still got pudding in the house no
but I never turn it down when someone
offers it it was last time they offered
you putting on something that wasn't our
show
they'd be nuts the people who offer
pudding that's really good now I'm sad
well he didn't eat the pudding but I'll
tell you what he did with it he went to
every store in this chain and bought
every last cup which you can imagine
he's walking through the stores with
grocery carts full of pudding people
were looking at him kind of weird you
know what his excuse was you know it's
1999 his excuse is y2k makes sense yeah
individual long expiration yeah lasts
for a long time we feel like whole
refrigerator with pudding one time
remember that yeah we did for the what
what your refrigerator says about you
but it was butterscotch flavor it's that
you shouldn't eat in here I know I
didn't I think he got mostly chocolate
but I mean he probably got whatever was
in sales right so what he did next was
he realized he had this big daunting
task he got over 12,000 cups of pudding
good gosh oh he had to get the barcodes
off everyone and he had a month to do it
because he wanted to get in on that
early bird stipulation so he asked his
wife and children to help him cut these
barcodes off well that's what that's
what you have those on the farm or help
with the code PC cottage so he realized
early and that it was going to take them
a lot longer than a month to get this
done so cleverly David went to a
Salvation Army a local one and he asked
the people there he said I've got all
this pudding if you donate volunteers to
cut off all the barcodes I'll give you
all the pudding and they did it
here's the cool thing they did it they
said sure we'll do it we'll take the
pudding they got people to help them do
it but when you when you cut the barcode
off I thought it exposed the pudding no
no it's on the it's on the thing that
holds them all together yeah it's on the
cardboard that holds the other thing
together it's not on the pudding cups
Wow then in it that's they're not for
individual resale that's weird that that
there would be six UPC's on one of those
then and not the individual container
but a man's it is what it is Nikola
Wiggly you know so Salvation Army got
involved so then he was able to because
it was a big donation he was able to
write that off on his taxes at the end
of the year so he got 800 bucks back for
making this choice another loophole
he spent 3000 bucks on the pudding so in
reality 2,200 bucks on the pudding okay
doesn't seem like a lot but he was able
to get it done in the month send it in
and he also had some Kansas soup like he
did this before the pudding before he
got in on the good game and they were
like 90 cents a can so all in all he
sent in all of his bar codes and got
back 1 million two hundred and eighty
thousand frequent flyer miles 1 million
1 million this was one point almost 3
million yes they said in dollar value
it's about at the time I guess one
hundred thirty thousand fifty thousand
dollars so after he did this
it automatically gave him lifelong
access to the American air Oh as
American Airlines yeah American Airlines
advantage Gold Club I guess is what it's
called because if you get like a million
euros or whatever you automatically
become a high roller all kinds of perks
for life for him and his family when
they travel he got into that door that
you don't notice at the airport I call
you of the cockpit door your friend tell
no not not to the lane in the airport
yeah it's like the one at Disneyland
the secret access to the lounge door
that you don't notice until your friend
tells you if you get this credit card
along with me we can go into these
together and then he spends the next two
minutes of me trying to talk me into
getting the card along with them so we
can cavort in these like crystal and
case tiles well they're not that lounge
I do have bathrooms that have closeted
commodes you need that that's worth any
amount you can sleep in there but I got
a beef with American Airlines I had a
Twitter beef with them really had a like
a three or four tweet back and forth
with American Airlines didn't involve
putting you know a couple months ago
what was it about it was about it was
about the shape of the seats and how my
wife and I coming back from Mexico got
onto the plane and noticed that she was
like why am i why is my head so far
forward I was like well why is my head
so far forward like I can't lean back
this is super uncomfortable started
looking around and everybody looked
uncomfortable I was like I'm six seven
you're five three we're both
uncomfortable and something's gotta be
done about the spectrum it's like if
we're both uncomfortable is it somebody
who's the Goldilocks right in the middle
it feels good I don't know that
everybody looks uncomfortable I tweeted
at them about how they needed to do
something about their their seat design
and they tweeted back at me and then
they asked me for like design a you know
direction they wanted you to redesign it
and I panicked a little bit I said a
hamburger button you went comedic I miss
a cheeseburger button and they were like
okay you know we'll work on it and I was
like well first let's work on the other
thing and then I kind of backed off a
little bit anyway I still you know I
still think I got to fix that did you
hear that Alex tweeted at Delta did he
tell you this story I heard it I saw his
tweet I don't want to go off too much in
a tangent but he was going to his
brother's wedding
and his dad booked the wrong flight for
him and so he was like and then he
looked and they were sold out to get
there so he tweeted it Delta I miss my
brother's wedding
yeah help yeah and other people tweeted
at for him in the road him gave him a
number to call he called it and they
hooked him up yeah mythical beasts help
Alex get to his brother's frickin
wedding yes he made it I didn't hear the
story awesome it was a lot long I gave
you the short version I should have let
him tell you but yeah well we don't we
don't talk about yeah I don't over great
great to talk yeah okay 1.2 something
yeah 1 points you sup million so he's
been since then which first of all is a
lot of miles yeah
hundred and so one hundred and thirty
thousand one hundred minus the
twenty-two hundred I'm doing math here a
fifty thousand fifty you're not doing
the math well fifty hundred
I mean he's it like one hundred forty
seven hundred forty eight thousand
dollars profit yeah unless he paid his
wife and kids or the volunteers at the
which he did she never volunteers paid
and pudding dude made Bank yeah and he
got the hookup at the lounge yes and he
got he got free flights yes free flights
not only that he's completed the free
flights was the equivalent of the money
yeah but since then he's been he always
keeps an eye out for a frequent flyer
cuz apparently these people get obsessed
with frequent fliers there's like a
whole cult for it yeah he kept an eye
out for other promotions and he's
capitalized I think he earns more
because he's gold status anyways yeah
the dude come compound effect yes he has
right now they say he has over four
million miles in various accounts he's
flown to over 20 countries taken
numerous vacations and he never has to
pay for a flight ever again the rest of
his life Wow so the moral of story is
you make a healthy choice even if it's
for pudding you could be a high roller
and you know what he should be there's
there's no questioning to this one this
guy should be celebrated
good for you Chris Chris Jim Robby Jim
David Phillips
David David Bobby Chris whatever I'm not
my name this next guy a lot of work
though that's a lot of legwork it is now
we could celebrate that guy I don't know
if we could celebrate this guy cuz he
was in his clever is David he was more
lucky so let me tell you about damn
quart of it it is part of the order life
sometimes you fall through the loophole
he did he was a manhole yes this Dan
Sanders this guy is from Australia he
was living in a small town called longer
otta or something like that at the time
this is 2011 he's 29 years old he's a
bar man which I learned is Australian
for bartender I did wild guess sexist
though sexist yeah they need to change
it down they should change it down there
okay he's out drinking with his friends
one night he goes to the ATM because
he's low on funds he opens up his
account
some studies yes that's slang yeah he
goes to withdraw money do it only has
three dollars in a savings account so he
he what a jerk yeah he goes into his
credit card to transfer money into his
savings which I know you could do cash
advance they called yeah that's what he
did that's trouble you basically have to
pay interest to on borrowing against
your credit card okay
horrible idea I've never done I thought
it was an Australian thing but you know
I learned so he sent over 200 bucks into
his savings account mm-hmm and when he
did it it said that can't the
transaction was cancelled but the 200
bucks showed up in his savings account
and he didn't see his B couldn't see his
balance for his credit card so he
thought oh it worked
so he went hung out with his friends
some more he made a second trip back to
the ATM later that night and did another
200 bucks and it worked again he said
declined but then the money show yeah it
said like it was some type of
malfunction but the money still showed
up but shouldn't have gone over but it
did and so the night carried on this
dude he was a bar a bartender he made
seven hundred bucks a week so yeah he
made a third trip back to the ATM that
night and he went to he maxed it to the
two thousand to see if it would work and
it went through put the money in his
wallet went home woke up the next day he
thought he had been dreaming opens up as
well and sure enough there's a 2 grand
yeah he should have stopped there
probably like every please speaking okay
right so he should have done one stop
now
let me ask the question at speaking of
ethics so now on the surface of this I
wouldn't do it because I wouldn't even
have to get to the moral question
because I would I would be like you
can't you don't get away with this kind
of stuff
they're this there's computers in there
there's a camera you're gonna be caught
so just don't be stupid but let me pose
the question if you knew that
unequivocally you would not be caught
for it when would you have stops oh and
and and would you have stopped would you
have reported the initial $200 just
moral question
I feel like I might have gone as far as
he went I mean what's my Jean Valjean
situation I mean am I am i you're a man
that has $3 I'm a man it's got three
dollars in my savings account yeah yes
but I'm I'm yucking it up my buddies
yeah for the brewskis I don't but that's
I'm judging him now but I am him so I'm
judgment yeah you got to be him to be in
this situation he's down and out man
three bucks all I needs is a little time
with his friends a little more time but
given these circumstances I went right
though I would have never done it no cuz
you're out and too scared but I know
like when I got my first ATM card and
went to a ATM machine to withdraw money
I remember having a fantasy of like man
that'd be cool if I could just keep on
taking money out and never declines my
account right that's what it was yeah I
mean I think the thing is about the
ethical side of this thing is that there
are really no decisions that are made in
an ethical vacuum right so you know so
my question is probably even it's an
impossible scenario but but it the
question you posed is the answer I gave
in buddy system which I can't quite
remember which is something like just
because somebody doesn't see it does it
just can't say it just because somebody
didn't see you do it doesn't mean that
it's okay that you do that's called
antes it it's called integrity link
it's called integ what I'm saying that
you don't trap me pure it's a hyper your
integrity is actually an impossible
situation because really you're always
dealing in a world of real consequences
right point taken
so just steal the money well that's what
Rhett say let me tell you what this guy
did because this guy had some fun so he
maxed it out he and 2500 bucks yeah he
was doing he was sitting pretty he kept
going back okay so after a first week
maybe a little longer
he got 20,000 bucks in his account it
wasn't his account or was it a
particular ATM no it was no it was a a
big ATM out there I think they call them
NAB so thank you but it's a big one out
there but not a fan you location it all
any of them anywhere he went as long as
they had this ATM which took his card
this this it was a malfunction and it
couldn't be the only person that was
benefiting from this right if other
people could have done it too
but he was the one that figured it out
how sad the only one the only one okay
so what he did then next was he started
gambling right as you would do
might as well he's already made a lot of
good decisions he's already been real
lucky yeah but here's know you're lucky
a little you get lucky more yeah he was
gambling they have a gambling system
there it's like a machine you can gamble
on horses and he was doing it in his own
bar so and he was doing it an amount of
money that people around in this small
town red flags yes red flags were going
up so he got fired from his job and I
think it was because they thought he was
into something shady and they were
worried about causing some trouble at
their establishment so they let him go
his girlfriend caught wind of this and
she dumped him via text message now I
think his luck is turning his luck is
turning so he says as this is this is
all happening now he's out of a job and
out of a girlfriend he wrote on one hand
you've lost your girlfriend lost your
job but on the other hand hey you got
unlimited funds let's smash it up for a
bit let's sort things out so he
continues his withdrawals now if you
told me that he literally started
smashing things up I'd believe you at
this point with this guy well I'll tell
you thank you is a euphemism he started
going to all the fanciest restaurant in
godou alone no he was he was going with
escorts okay of course yeah can't go
alone can't go alone to be escorted yeah
guys be safe kids yes he was going
places and private jets on vacation he
was him Annette putting him in the guy
in the fanciest hotel rooms he could buy
he said this this is a quote just to
kind of give you an idea where he where
he was at I've never felt more alive
than when I was charging on my credit
card with the NAB card I could be anyone
I wanted to be go anywhere I wanted to
go do anything as long as I had the card
in my back pocket I felt like a king I
felt like a rockstar probably looked
like a fat white Kanye West but you felt
like you were
Kanye West is that is that when she
Kanye West is showing up is that it that
was the kind of mentioned yeah you gotta
have a good tease say the white Kanye
we're gonna have a good tease you know
elegy teases are supposed to be
misleading right it's not to miss Liddy
because we got to have the tease as
always work that quote that you just
read of him makes no sense no I think it
would be a perfect commercial for the
NAB yeah make on an amp read the part
that when you want to feel like a white
pine us know before that yeah yeah that
he could be I've never felt more alive
than when I was charging on my credit
card with an AB card I could be anyone I
wanted to be with an anywhere I wanted
to go I could be anyone I wanted to be
including a white guy anyway I like that
I like that be white Kanye West with the
NAB somebody needs to do a bold campaign
they should have done it man so he went
back to Melbourne where he's from
because he was getting a little bit of
heat in that current town when he met
new friends and he had all this money he
would tell people he was either a poker
player or a surgeon or an investment
banker so I had all these aliases and
then there was even a point
those are occupations Kevin there is
even a boy what's your name surgeon
there was a point where he actually
figured out another way to hack the ATM
yeah and I couldn't wrap my brain around
this one but it was it was something
about a trick the ATM he could double
his money by transferring money from the
ATMs credit account option to his
MasterCard even though he only had one
credit card he explained it in this
interview and I didn't really fully
understand it but it was I can't I'm
surprised that no one else right he's
able to somebody else had to be doing
this it's yeah maybe they didn't do what
he did yeah and maybe and what we're
talking about there is you've had a way
of transferring the balance to a
different card and then you could go and
use that card I think that's what he's
like ping against that card yeah so yeah
so this is even more effective because
now you're not carrying around a bunch
of cash yes you're just using a credit
card and paying off the balance with
this crazy ATM trick I believe that's
exactly what it was
free money coming out the machines free
money that totaled the amount in four
and a half months of one point six
million dollars
yes he he was alive in so the beauty of
that is you know you don't have to
convert it to flyer miles he was
spending it like a white Kanye West
you know frequency what is the white cut
thats so racist by the what does that
even mean I don't even want to I don't
know what no II didn't mean I just threw
it out there what well he is white and
he's white and he thought Kanye he felt
like he was living a lifestyle like
Kanye West
yeah yeah right but just white but just
white yeah is why he's not racist yeah
okay so he was he started feeling guilty
after 1.6 million dollars he started
feeling guilty it caught up with him he
went in saw psychologist and after
seeing a psychologist he stopped making
the transfers and then he eventually
reported himself oh so his conscience
caught up with him the bank told him
that the police were under there was an
investigation going on it took three and
a half years before they finally charged
him but they did charge him so for three
and a half years so they knew something
was going on because they keep it they
keep track and we're losing we've lost
one point six million dollars somehow
took him three and a half years to
figure it out but they did he got
sentenced to there was a hundred and
eleven offences relating to fraud and
theft sentence of one year in prison and
when he got out he had 18 months of
community service and then he had to pay
back $250,000 compensation to the bank
man so he stole a million he only up to
jail for prison it for a year and young
he said it is okay in his defense this
is the kind of thing that he did not go
to the ATM saying I'm gonna scan this
ATM right it was an error on the part of
the bank that led to an opportunity that
he then took advantage of mm-hmm so I
could see how the senate's would be
somewhat lenient yeah it's not like
stealing 11.6 million dollars
premeditated it's like somebody you know
leaves a french fry behind million
dollar for a billion dollar on your life
like if you if you go to a store and you
and you you you give them a large bill
and they give you back a whole lot more
money then you
were paid they give you the change
that's happened to me and I have always
given it back but is how I have gotten
ya extra cheeseburger I've gotten like
oh yeah I've gotten like an extra
cheeseburger my combo yeah well cuz what
they're what throw it away throw it away
and I hate it when that happens here I
hate it when happens when I give
something back that I didn't want you
hate it when you get an extra
cheeseburger I know it may be let me
finish the thing that I hate is when I
get I give something back that I don't
even like and then I see him throw that
in the trash can I was like man yeah I
probably could like part of it give me
the thing that I like that I meant to
order but also let me keep the thing I
didn't order so I can eat the parts of
it that I bet I could like when you say
I didn't order the mashed potatoes and
that but they're there yeah they take
your whole especially when they take
your whole plate that has your don't
take my whole plate man just let me eat
these taters that I didn't order bleep
give me anything what are you gonna do
we taters missin free table before your
error well the last thing this guy said
that I read about him was it was never
about the actual money it was just about
the journey I believe that I kind of
believe it too
he just wanted the thrill he just wanted
the thrill it was about the money - yeah
based on the way you spin it okay now I
got two more for you and I really want
to get to the last one but I'm gonna
give you this third one here it's a
little bit shorter but I think you'll
like this one yeah don't don't hold back
I'm not gonna hold back so this is a guy
named Bryan bellman and he's the owner
of a bar called the rock this is in
Maplewood Minnesota and back in 2000 in
the the rock is a hard rock heavy metal
bar so in 2011 black t-shirt loud music
and leather pants fried gizzards yeah so
in 2007 2008 Minnesota introduced a new
state ban on smoking and restaurants and
other night spots I think a lot of
states did what year do you say 2007 oh
yeah right yeah earlier in North
Carolina was it
which is surprising don't you think I
don't know the date honestly I don't
know but I mean 10 years ago that feels
right yeah yeah so he had to have all of
his customers stopped smoking
and it resulted in the 30% decline in
revenue for him so bad business for him
right good health but bad business so he
read the fine print just like our first
fellow and in the band
there was one rare exception to smoking
indoors and it was smoking in theatrical
productions loud right cuz you got to
have your actors smoke if you're on
stage and you're playing a smoker smoker
got a smoke
yo yes exactly so what Brian did was he
made it what he created theater night
y'all acting right everybody's acting
everybody that's exactly what it was he
literally called his patrons actors on
theater night they're acting like
they're in a wedding a metal bar yes but
they were acting and they were playing
themselves before October 1st which is
when the band took place back then so he
said you know it even impact like
somebody did though you got to be
yourself it was called his play was
called before the band that's what the
production was called and it never stop
never stop it was an ongoing production
listen I gotta give this guy some credit
right I gotta give this guy's credit cuz
first of all I'll just be I'll just go
out come out and say I don't know what I
think about the smoking ban just just
from from a political from a from a from
a I don't know from a legal champ what
do you think about smoking
oh I don't yeah I think smoking is
stupid hey you know you're not
necessarily stupid if you smoke but I
think the choice to smoke is a stupid
choice obviously you shouldn't smoke I
don't smoke I don't promote smoking man
but if somebody who owns a restaurant
says at my restaurant I'm gonna make the
choice that if you want to come in here
and smoke then shouldn't that restaurant
owner have the ability to make that
choice because then if I don't like
smoking like most people then I just
don't go to that restaurant if there's a
bunch of people want to get together and
smoke in a bar then shouldn't they just
if it's not impacting anybody else
outside of the people who made that
decision can't they just make the
decision to go in there and and be
stupid if they want to do we really need
to tell people you can't it's like you
can't go to a place where they smoke
really I agree with you on this one
and I think there is an element of
protecting the public if you have a
place that's not 100% smoking like they
had this they had like non-smoking
sections and then people were in the
public was endangered through secondhand
smoke so that's what right well the
public should just make the decision to
not go to that restaurant and then
people will be like okay more people
want me to not offer smoking but
shouldn't there be some enclaves where
people who really insist on smoking can
go and smoke I mean it's gonna be the
minority it's gonna be just a few it
right well it started a trend and there
is like 30 other bars yes well I I'm
just just to just to put a capper on
this it's just not that my response is
well the analogy is like how Chipotle
treats their chickens in their porks in
their cows pigs no okay you know that
like okay then there'd be more
restaurants that are making things in
like a humane way if that's what you
care about or in a way that's better for
you it's like well that the the the
market forces don't they're not that
effective I'm just saying I I believe
across the board that's a way to combat
problems is with truth and the truth is
smoking is bad for you causes lung
cancer it increases all kinds of
illnesses it's horrible for that means
shouldn't do it that means putting a
cigarette warning like one of those
horrible cigarette warnings that covers
the whole door to every smoking bar
cigarette warning sure yeah yeah but you
can also go in there no oh it smells
like smoke in here I'm leaving because I
don't believe in smoking and I don't
support places to smoke I'm just saying
where'd you put the truth well you got
to put it on the product let the people
make the decision well it was good
business for him because it brought his
revenue back up the thing I like about
what he did was that it was creative and
yeah fun yes and everyone's acting like
hey guess who I am today me from a few
months ago exactly they had like a
curtain on the front door that said like
Stage Door entrance and they had a thing
that said props and underneath the props
was ashtrays
and so it was spread around a bunch of
bars did it became a pretty popular
thing but the state cracked down on it
and they said that this is you can't
exploit this loophole we'll find you for
$10,000 if you're doing this they kept
on anyways but then as soon as a few of
the bar owners had to go to court and
they lose pretty much as [ __ ] yeah yeah
what you so because the other thing I'll
say is if that's the law which it was
bring this obviously is not sustainable
this is obviously not consistent with
the spirit of the law which is people
not smoking inside of the restaurant and
again just say it's a play cuz then I
could be like well it's illegal to
murder people but you know what you can
murder people in movies you know yeah
yeah I don't want to go to a bar where
or any I could die well sadly that bar
went out of business the bar that that
was the end for the rock yeah and many
bars like it yeah now those people are
just staying at home listening to heavy
metal music that's right smoking saving
money yeah okay now we're gonna go on to
the last and my favorite story this is
about a man named Dennis Hope who claims
to be the richest man in the solar
system he's also known as the Moon Man
you guys are gonna love this I had to
check so many times this is really real
so many times I couldn't believe it you
might have Snopes
I went to Snopes I went I went
everywhere man the richest man in the
universe the richest man in the solar
system solecism is still pretty big it
is big and here's why okay as far as he
comes he's concerned Dennis hope he owns
most of it hmm okay
they explain why in the early 1980s
Dennis was unemployed for about a year
and he thought he'd be a good property
owner and he make a good living in real
estate mm-hmm so he looked out his
window and he saw what looked like a
pretty big piece of property that nobody
owned which was the movie he remembered
he had taken a political science course
in college you think you know everything
he remembered that remember I mentioned
to you guys the United Nations outer
space treaty mm-hmm this is a 1967
treaty that said no country could own
the moon but it had nothing about
individuals
so he not live oh there's my loophole so
he jumped in that loophole he wrote a
letter to the United Nations saying the
moon was his he'd even asked for
permission clarity he declared the moon
his and he asked them the government to
send him a plaque pretty much he said
you need to provide me with a legal
reason why an individual could not claim
ownership of the moon and he never heard
back that was all he needed hmm I'm with
him on this here's a quote I sent the
United Nations a declaration of
ownership detailing my intent to
subdivide and sell the moon and have
never heard back it's gonna make
subdivisions up there he is going to he
did man on alera states there's a
loophole in the treaty it does not apply
to individuals so he started a business
called the lunar embassy he's the CEO
which is not chief executive officer
it's the celestial executive officer of
course the president of the galactic
government aka the head cheese of the
lunar embassy there's a website for this
man boy so he's still active he's still
active this is gonna blow your mind
here's what it says you go to the
website
welcome to the computer center of the
lunar embassy the leaders in
extraterrestrial real estate and the
only company in the world to be
recognized to possess a legal basis for
selling and registering extraterrestrial
properties recognized by so let's break
this down firstly the first three were
welcome to what the computer center of
the lunar embassy okay the computer
center he doesn't understand how website
how's he supposed to know anything about
real estate if you don't know what what
a web look maybe that's what they call
it on the moon if you don't know the
computer center computer center could it
website could have maybe it won out but
maybe computer center was the next best
thing
welcome to think of nothing better than
website that's not computer center I
can't man and internet internet spotter
Center man it gets better guys if you
are looking for an extraterrestrial
property you have come to the right
place this really is the cheapest real
estate in the universe and if you think
this must be a really good joke please
know that
is not for more info go to the woods he
sells it by the acre what does he do he
sells it there's a bisection on this
right here by now he has moon property
Mars property Venus property he's got
mercury property he's got so he he moved
on to every planet in the solar system
yes now does he say he owns all of it
and he's subdividing it or is he does he
give a little for the scientists he does
actually yeah yeah yeah he has a basis
set aside just for them scientist
centers yeah okay set aside just for
those what's the price okay so today's
price is $24.99 for an acre
oh that sounds she's like getting in on
the freak out whether it man like this
is like going into Texas like 200 years
ago and buying ten thousand acres and
then being a barren we could be barons
right now it's pretty barren
I wonder if anyone has given this game
yeah I mean what's this guy's revenue
I'm about to blow you guys minds here in
a second you know what listen okay
this dude has created an opportunity for
stupid people to give him money that is
what they call businessman to date and
this is this is I think this article I
read is a little bit old so it's
probably more than this he sold more
than six hundred million acres hundred
million acres of land but you know who's
buying that guy with the ATM card it is
you know who else his I'm gonna tell you
three of his customers are former
presidents of the United States George
HW Bush Jimmy Carter and Ronald Reagan
no no it's real you know this is real I
have I have looked up deep into this guy
and everything I'm finding of him is
real they made it I think they made a
documentary on this guy or other people
that were related to the moon and he
talks about it you can see it on his
website there's a there's an ad it you
can go to his website buy an acre and
add it to a cart you can add well acre
moon to a car
but how do we know that this because
when you heart so when you went to
Snopes yeah what what did they say snow
comes up with another couple that was
trying to do the same thing similar but
they but their their story wasn't true
this guy story everything ok this you
google this guy and it comes up on like
let me see his is he said it was six
hundred thousand six hundred million
makers because that means this guy's one
of the richest people in the world he's
got like made over nine million dollars
doing this
now that sounds somewhat reasonable yeah
but not really but okay
so he that he's made yes you're right
the six now the 6mm million doesn't make
sense acres that be and let unless he's
unless it was back to what you said
about giving chunks of it away give
people which i think is what it was
different deal but when you look him up
he comes up on all kinds of articles us
news viced in an article at New York
Times like he's on every mainstream
market say tonight I secure yeah that I
think it was maybe Vice I read that from
nine million dollars this guy's made
it's crazy man so what does he live
unless you ant it yeah he's got space on
the moon that's for sure so he once said
that he sold a country size plot of land
2.6 million acres for two hundred and
fifty thousand dollars and he said that
the largest property for sale is a
continent sized piece of property five
million acres which cost thirteen
million dollars he hasn't sold that yet
or any of those yet okay so if you've
got two hundred and fifty thousand
dollars to spend it doesn't mean you're
necessarily smart but it means that
you're not real dumb right so it's one
of those things that like in the future
when we're colonizing other planets well
let's go past that once planets are
colonized if you then like I went there
to visit and you introduced me to
someone said this is what's the guy's
name
his name is that Dennis hope Dennis hope
he's a guy who owns most of this sir hey
no he's the guy who owns a big plot on a
lot of different places he's not
all of it but I could see how this guy
would be able to finagle his way into
whenever that does happen in the future
somehow because of these exercises now
it does pay off
but I'm very suspicious that anything
he'll be dead probably no no there's the
cryogenic technology and because that's
real as well yeah here's the Vice
article so they asked him how much land
have you sold for he said well this is
the only job I've had since 1995 which
is when I started doing this full-time
we've sold 611 million acres of land on
the moon 325 million acres on Mars and a
combined 125 million acres on Venus and
Mercury and he also said I live on Venus
and Mercury I know no no I can't live
any of these boys you can't but I mean
Mars Mars in the moon or he's a lightly
better candidate right he thinks he's
gonna prove you wrong he's he's banking
on people yeah literally I think they're
gonna prove legitimacy of the moon right
now in terms of I mean I know the you
know we put up American flag the UN
thing applies to that that everyone
agreed in the United Nations that
countries can't on it yes and there was
a reason yeah they're a representative
from International Institute of space
law at the United Nations they say they
said that the United Nations never
responded because the treaty applies to
both countries and its citizens and they
basically said what he's doing is just
selling them pieces of paper yeah well
yeah and they went they didn't want to
give him credence with a response well
this is like though you won't this is
like those sovereign citizen people
right you know there's no you won't
there's a lot of them you know about you
know about yes like the law doesn't
apply to me because I'm a sovereign
citizen watch it Google sovereign
citizens owned by police or you will you
will be entertained because if you are
in the if you are in that particular
country and you're violating the law you
will still suffer the consequences of
violating the law regardless of what
your perspective is which is what's
going to happen in this guy
what do you mean owned by police like
like people doing something being pulled
over and saying in that bit the cop asks
them for their license and registration
they say I don't have to give that to
you I'm not subject to the laws of this
country I'm a sovereign citizen and then
basically the cops are like will you
stop him you're subject to the effect of
this taser you know okay so but I just
misunderstood what you meant by own poem
I should have used poem 27 you want me
to you want me to find out about
sovereign lands that policeman oh yeah
that's that's also gonna be very
interesting for me later but I mean how
do I don't haven't thought about this at
all I just know that like you know Elon
Musk is is well on his way to having
something on Mars right I mean which I
don't I don't know how I feel about it
but I think eventually like a thousand
years from now whatever it's inevitable
right that they'll be it's some sort of
present it seems inevitable and I will
bet you a lot of Bitcoin that that guy
will be one of them somehow he'll be on
there no you know how you get in I'll be
out he'll be honored that they will like
somebody who hope may be somebody who
listen to this ear biscuit who becomes
some sort of scientist and then writes
it down somewhere that's the only way
somebody's gonna find out about me
somebody's gonna as an Ohio County as an
homage to this guy is gonna name
something after him but that is at that
is his best hope that is his best hope
best possible scenario for this guy I
think his best hope was that has made a
lot of money man
yeah it's like he tapped into the
greatest gag gift of all time if it's
true what what they're saying what he
says he's made off of this if it's true
I mean I kind of got handed a guy yeah
yeah yeah I'm twenty-five dollars an
acre yeah I mean a lot of people would
buy it just for that just to say they
did it right like I mean we bought I
bought you that grove of you know
redwood trees for your birthday and it
was legitimate to help a cause but it
was also fun yeah and I named a star
after you remember that that's right I
also star that's also a pointless well I
think about it I'm gonna busy you bring
it up you're gonna visit that star
I I think they I think he might be
getting a lot of money just just out of
the entertainment value well my first
thought when I saw it was this might be
a good suggestion for when you guys
birthday gifts right yeah he did it man
come October I know what you're getting
a plot yeah I mean exactly it's a it's a
it's a good he does yeah is it does it
have gold foil I think you can put your
name on there and there is a a lunar tax
from what I read also so you pay a
little more than the $24.99 oh yeah he's
got it so let's get more money please
so can I just can I just buy an acre a
certificate yeah probably I think I
think this isn't what I think is going
on with this guy I think he's I'm gonna
give him a little credit
I think he's super smart I think he
knows exactly what he's doing and I
think he knew that people would would go
along with this even people like us who
were like this is bullcrap but we're
gonna do it anyway yes it's fun yeah and
he was like if I come out and say that
I'm you know I don't believe this and
it's not it's cool to be a part of it me
and you were like good this cool comedy
idea you gonna like the moon no but like
do it the joke of you owning part of the
moon is also on him right and you know
he's a genius
he's a genius they're all geniuses in
their moon man you started off man well
I'm gonna give him a little credit now
he's a genius you know right was gonna
name this guy gene doesn't take much man
I didn't but he did well he can't rat
doesn't have the authority to name
someone a genius well the United Nations
genius countries countries can't do that
but individuals can and I did it first
so it's you are whatever I name you
first he is an individual thank you this
is some genius research that went into
this I think that you know always look
for the loophole and listen to your
conscience
right before you jump don't take
advantage of people take advantage of
loopholes yes they can't feel anything
that loot may tighten around your waist
Oh or you may
depending slim me down yeah or it made
you stay open forever like a Stargate
[Music]
there you have it aren't your biscuit
with Kevin about loophole we jump
through lots of loopholes Lupo Lupo and
then we came out the other side yeah
full circle it's got me thinking at full
loophole mm-hmm got me thinking I should
be looking for more loopholes you know
II just you just need to it takes work
that's the thing it's like whenever the
one that sticks with me the most is the
putting one because I feel like pudding
III default thought to pudding but you
would never ever never do the million
years do something like that tedious
even though you're really tedious about
certain things but I don't have collect
coupons I don't have time to do any that
like the coupon clipping thing that
Christie had friends I know Jesse had
friends who really got into that her mom
got into it and then they wanted they
thought they were gonna get into that
way back in like when we first got
married because you had like a coupon
notebook
they're like the things we used to
collect baseball cards in that was a
whole lot of work and it fizzled out
very quickly because there's a lot of
money though yep
well the cost of time the cost of time
is money man time is what she can't buy
back there are some people who never get
that and they spent a lot of time doing
something to save money not realizing
that if they were putting that energy
and time into something else they may be
able to make more money than their
savings we want to thank you mythical
beasts for lending your time to us you
know what because and we'll never pay it
back it's gone you know you lost all the
time that you spent listening to us but
you gained we want to thank you and
hopefully you did games yes this is not
a one-way thing right well I could hope
not
hopefully you gained something hopefully
if you're one of those people out there
right now with an app card in Australia
you've got a hot tip you're taking
advantage of that loophole hopefully you
will turn yourself in because sure they
closed it you'll go to prison just for
how long just a year and they live it up
now but yeah you got a you got to pay
the piper
what does it don't do it maybe when you
when you take get that cul-de-sac prime
location in Mars you can you can do it
there live it up there but for now just
let us know using hash tag ear biscuits
what do you think let's make this a
convo y'all we want to hear from you and
listen you on iTunes is also health
really we got to exploit that iTunes
loophole you know get the reviews get
the ratings game that system game that
help us gain the system that's what
we're about here all right we'll talk at
you next week
[Music]